at what age does the medical transition  begin with uh medication so medical  affirmation begins when the patient says  they're ready for it  so that could be  a kiddo who is just starting puberty  and panicking because they're getting  breast buds or their penis is getting  bigger and busier and they're worried  about all kinds of masculine changes and  that way puberty blockers which are  completely reversible  and don't have permanent effects are  wonderful because we can put that pause  on puberty just like if you were  listening to music you put the pause on  and we stopped the blockers and puberty  would go right  back to where it was the next note in  the song  just  what's that please  they're messing with your whole biology  biology  this is what's so sinister about it for  me is that human beings have a biology  and the fact that they're going to stop  a natural process within every human  being  says that there's something wrong